bienvenido veamos si podemos calcular
cuánto es 8 dividido entre 0.4 pausa
este vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy
bien estamos tratando de calcular cuánto
es 8 unidades divididas entre 4 décimas
una manera de hacer esto es pensar todo
en términos de décimas tenemos ocho
unidades una unidad es igual a diez
décimas por lo que ocho unidades es
igual a ochenta décimas así que esto es
igual a ochenta décimas y lo estoy
dividiendo entre cuatro décimas
dividimos entre cuatro décimas
entonces si tengo ochenta décimas y
quiero dividirlas en grupos iguales de
cuatro décimas cuántos grupos iguales
tendré bueno voy a tener veinte grupos
iguales de cuatro décimas cuatro grupos
iguales de 20 décimas resultan en 80
décimas 80 entre 4 es 20 de modo que 8
dividido entre 4 décimas es igual a 20
otra forma en que podríamos haber
abordado esto es pensar en términos de
fracciones podríamos haber dicho
8 dividido entre 4 décimas es lo mismo
que 8 dividido entre 4 décimas cuando se
divide entre una fracción es lo mismo
que multiplicar por el recíproco así que
esto es lo mismo que 8 por 10 sobre 4 o
podríamos verlo como 8 sobre 18 enteros
por 10 sobre 4 en el numerador obtienes
8 por 10 eso será igual a 80 y luego en
el denominador vamos a tener 1 por 4 que
va a ser igual a 4 entonces 80 cuartos y
80 dividido entre 4 una vez más es igual
a 20 hagamos otro ejemplo pero en este
caso tratemos con centésimas
voy a dibujar una línea aquí digamos que
alguien se acerca en la calle y te dice
rápido cuánto es 48 dividido entre 0.24
pausa este vídeo y trata de resolverlo y
te daré una pequeña pista las técnicas
que acabamos de hacer podrían aplicarse
con las centésimas también muy bien
trabajemos juntos en esto bueno una
forma de trabajar
esto es simplemente convertir todo a
fracciones el 48 en realidad solo puedo
escribir lo como 48 sobre 1 dividido
entre 24 centésimas así que cuando
dividimos entre una fracción es lo mismo
que multiplicar por el recíproco lo
hemos visto antes entonces esto es igual
a 48 sobre 1 por 100 sobre 24 y así en
nuestro numerador aquí será igual a 48
por 100 en realidad voy a escribir esto
como 48 por 100 en el numerador y
entonces nuestro denominador será 24 por
1 bueno eso es igual a 24 y cuál va a
ser el resultado 48% dividido entre 24
bueno podríamos dividir el numerador y
el denominador entre 24 si hacemos eso
48 dividido entre 24 es igual a 2 y 24
dividido entre 24 es 1 así que nos
quedamos con 2 por 100 dividido entre 1
bueno 2 por 100 es igual a 200 y luego
si divides esto entre
uno es igual a 200 y así esto es igual a
200 ahora otra forma en que podría haber
abordado esto es pensar en términos de
centésimas y así 48 unidades
es lo mismo que 4800 centésimas déjenme
escribir eso 4800 centésimas dividido
entre 24 centésimas de modo que si tengo
4800 centésimas y quiero dividirlo entre
grupos iguales de 24 centésimas cuántos
grupos iguales tendré bueno tendrás 4800
dividido entre 24 grupos iguales
entonces esto va a ser igual a 4800
dividido entre 24 ahora 4800 es
exactamente lo que teníamos aquí y ya
vimos que 4800 dividido entre 24 es
igual a 200 y si acabas de llegar a este
punto y te preguntas cómo puedo resolver
esto podrías decir permíteme dividir el
numerador y el denominador entre 24
podrías intentar expresar 4800
48% o incluso podrías decir que 48 es 24
por 2 y luego multiplicar eso por 100
para llegar a 4800 y luego la división
es un poco más directa pero el panorama
general es darse cuenta de que dividir
entre decimales no es una cosa
misteriosa cuando lo piensas en términos
de valor posicional o cuando lo piensas
en términos de fracciones